hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and this is actually take two for the
night i think we had an internet blip
there
uh and my stream got disconnected
but now i hopefully we are actually back
and live with a special tournament
edition
of the road 2000 that's right tonight is
the road 2000 championship part two
except it's not a championship it's just
a tournament but you should you should
still join anyway
because there are a fun a really cool
pro a ton of really fun prizes
uh on the line here so that's enough of
me
uh doing an intro because i already did
one of these and it didn't work
so now let me tell you guys how to join
hello hello everyone it looks like i'm
live for real this time
uh my my first go at it was unsuccessful
due to
something happening with my internet but
we're back now
and you guys should all join the
tournament now how do you join the
tournament it's not too late you have
another eight minutes
before the tournament starts you can and
should join
and what you have to do is go to our st
louis chess club chess.com team which
i'm gonna link
in the chat right now go to this link
join our team and then click on this
tournament
and that should take you to live chess
with the three minute the road to 2000
live stream tourney
starring me showing up on yourchest.com
and i see some people in the chess.com
chat already
hopefully they should also be joining
are we down to zero players in the event
this is not good this is not good
we are oh we're up to five players okay
all is well just had to refresh the page
there
uh okay so one more time how should you
join this event
first and foremost go to our chess club
page
that i have linked in the chat then it's
as simple as clicking on the tournament
and you are in there in there like
swimwear
okay there you go the road to 2000 see
it's right here
starts in eight minutes so you still
have time to join uh in the meantime
i have some stuff i do want to talk to
you about before we get underway here so
what are the prizes for this event why
should you plan this event it's a great
question
and one worth answering and the answer
to your great questions
uh are there are prizes on the line
third place gets in a free entry
into a february event that's uh
mike who runs all the tournaments has
told me about but in the kerfuffle i
have forgotten the details of
uh so let me pull that up really quick
but you get free entry into an event in
february which is sort of like
the grand finale for our tournaments
here
in the first couple months that's third
place
second place also gets you free entry
into this february event
which now that i'm looking through it
here
uh it's play like a champion it's the
play like a champion today
event on wednesday this february 17th
and so if you do well tonight get third
or second place you get free entry into
that event
which you will definitely want and then
first place the grand prize
the real reason why everybody is playing
here tonight
is a free lesson with yours truly and
that is a private lesson
none of this group class live stream
nonsense you and me
one on one and i tell you things
about a board game who could ask for
more
so that's why you should join and one
more time for anybody who's just joining
if you do want to play in this event and
you should then you just
click on the chess.com link i have sent
you in the chat room
and go ahead and join our club and join
the games now in the meantime we do
still have a few minutes before we get
going
and this believe it or not is not our
first time
uh doing one of these events and so i
wanted to highlight last event's winner
which is the one
the only chess playing wolf aka
danny machuca will he make another
appearance here tonight
trying to retain his title of the the
road to 2000
tournament winner uh unclear but you
know who
is going to be playing tonight danny's
main rival
from the previous event the one the only
mike cummer that's right we've got mike
cummer in the event tonight
and he sure gave danny a run for his
money
in the previous event and we're gonna
take a look at the game that decided
it all last time around while we wait to
get under
underway here so danny who did win the
entire event
had some interesting opening choices
throughout the event starting with one
f3 following that up with king to f2
really good stuff by danny so far and
mike
you know being a principal chess player
takes control of the center
we see danny developing out with e3 and
then mike has had enough of principles
he's trying to come after the white king
and this i i honestly i can't describe
this game to you you just have to see it
for yourself so black gets develops
white decides to develop some pieces as
well but mike's not having it
mike plays g5 sacrificing a pawn
seemingly for no reason but hoping to
get the bishop out
we see c3 by dany and now knight h3
danny finally develops the first piece
aside from the king
and let's just skip through all this
boring stuff we see a trade
rook h3 to g3 the machuca rook
kind of getting activated but then mike
plays queen h4
and honestly danny's totally busted here
after c4
we see e4 by mike and then
big mistake by by danny taking on d5
hanging the rook on a1
it all could have been over here for
danny all the rooks are falling off the
board
see danny gets a minor piece back but
it's not meant to be
this rook on g3 is is under fire
and then yeah here hear it all it all
changes mike
for no reason at all uh hangs this
bishop on
f4 you didn't even need to play bishop
e5 but uh i think it's fine too
you just have to not hang this bishop
for nothing knight f6
was the move in order to defend the pawn
on e4
and then black's going to follow that up
with your g8 and white is just totally
busted
so instead of all this though we do see
mike still coming out on top
winning the rook but then it all starts
going wrong
my queenside castles is up a ton of
material is coming after the white king
but then just like that the queen hanks
and and you know watching live i thought
this was it
i thought it was over i thought mike uh
you know had a shot at victory but now
it's
you know now danny had secured the win
but boy was i wrong
boy was i wrong despite being down a
full queen
we see danny play the move g3
why did danny play g3 i do not know but
look at how bad this move is look at the
bar
look at that go clearly danny had to
stop this pawn from going any further
and capture on h3 or even just
you know retreat back with something
like bishop f1 instead though
mike now has a very powerful pawn and
intends to use it like look at this
look at this stuff and then all of a
sudden uh it it didn't matter anyways
mike takes on c6 and and that's the
entire story we see a check
a check a check and now there's no
knight takes g3
and uh and yeah and danny is back in
control
goes on to easily win the game but had
mike just played the move king to a8
now there's no more checks and this
queen
cannot get back to the g3 pawn mike is
gonna play knight takes g3 on the next
turn
and then h1 queen and win the game so it
was that close
it was that close instead we see danny
actually running away with it
with the extra queen managed to hold it
all together
and ends up drawing the game
because he flags in this position
however a draw
was enough for danny to to win the game
is this a warm up
so if you're just joining it's not too
late you guys
need to join the tournament tonight
uh this is what we are looking at here
the road 2000
live stream tournament is what is going
on and the way to do that
is to click the link that i posted in
the chat
which is the uh link
sorry let me find find my bearings here
which is this link this link right here
that i'm gonna post again
click on this whoa don't click on that
okay just scroll up in the chat and
click on the link that i posted
that takes you to our club page and from
our club page
you can join the road to 2000 tournament
we've got 20 players in here
one is a national master some really
strong people
joining this event really strong people
joining this event
can you watch the stream while playing
uh yes uh and actually
my mishaps while i was starting to get
going here
may be a little bit uh detrimental to
that
but i think there is enough delay that
you you should feel free to watch the
stream while you play
i'm probably not going to give like you
know direct move
uh recommendations or anything in the
interest of fairness
but you know i'll more so just be
covering the action telling you what's
going on
can we get rid of the 2000 plus players
since it's a road to 2000
hey we're inclusive here anyone can be
on the road
2000 uh even if you're above 2000 there
is always a road
back to 2000. maybe they're just
approaching it from a different angle
you never know maybe i'm on the road
2000
so all players welcome even those above
2000
because they may be trying to find their
way back
unable to log in disaster elvis disaster
disaster and it looks like actually
the games are underway now i don't know
if it will let you leap join this event
but it looks as though it has started
so let's jump into it here let's take a
peek at
uh mike's game so mike here with the
black pieces
is actually the uh runner up
to last uh last year's event uh the 2020
version of the road to 2000 tournament
mike got second place in that fiasco of
a game
that we saw against danny machuca so i'm
sure mike is going to be looking
to uh to improve
upon that last year's performance and
indeed
he may be trying can we play absolutely
all you have to do
is join the tournament which i'm linking
in the chat i think you can light join
i'm not 100 certain but i'm pretty
pretty sure you can late join
maybe i could do a lee chess tournament
that is a question for mike mike
organizes all these events and uh i
think they're starting to to get some
popularity on chess.com
so we're sticking with chess.com for now
anyways what's going on
in this game let us flip back a little
bit
see what we're looking at here mike
plays the sicilian we get a knight c6
and it looks like the classic e4f4 type
of sicilian
grand prix attack type stuff we see mike
expanding early on
on the queen side and actually uh
white seems to have thought that their
knight was trapped it could have
retreated back to e3
but instead we see the sacrifice of the
peace and mike
is already ahead uh in this game looks
quite good
do i mean fun master mike i mean mike
cummer of the st louis chess club
he has been uh at the st louis chess
club
since it first became a chess club
really
um no not fm mic different mic
different mic anyways with that out of
the way i think mike's got this one in
the bag up a full piece
let's check in on board one uh we have a
national master
that's my title uh national master
limelight is in the events
and is potentially looking looking to
win so let's see what's going on
and yeah somewhat surprisingly
uh limelight seems to be playing for
checkmate but
if if the checkmate doesn't sort of pan
out here i think
white may actually be in some
substantial trouble
perhaps they were considering playing
knight g5 on the previous turn
and just ignoring the queen but i think
queen c2 there is probably what was
bothering white to stop this checkmate
now it's a question of
can black find some way to deal with
this threat and i suspect
you know maybe something like this
should just be played and actually
limelights down a few pieces here like
there there is a queen on the board
but uh but you know i'm looking at two
rooks and a bishop in exchange for it
uh and in fact black is attempting to
keep all of the mix
all of the material i i don't know if
that is the correct way to go about
things
but uh maybe black is looking to to
trade off some pieces
in this manner am i analyzing the games
as they play
yes i am giving commentary on the games
commentating the games
as they are in action here and i think
that the delay on youtube
is long enough such that there there
won't be any issues
with uh giving an unfair advantage to
the players but if you are worried about
that
then feel free to mute the stream whilst
your games are in progress
uh okay continuing on yet i suspect now
that things have gotten a little bit out
of hand this g6
f5 stuff probably wasn't the way to go
for black
now it looks as though it's just going
to be impossible to stop the checkmate
my idea for black was to give some of
the material
back actually play rookie one and rook
takes c4
sacrificing the rook for the knight and
then you know it's a lot easier to not
get checkmated by a lone queen
than it is to be checkmated by a queen
and a knight because together these two
pieces are just
too powerful and we're gonna see david i
think
fall to checkmate uh by the way
mike does go on to win his game by
resignation looks like mike just has
many more
pieces than uh than his opponent there
okay and with that we are seeing many
results
in round one so far we do have a few
games in progress
uh let's check in on board two which is
cho ruben cho against chess
lebanese salah and yeah chess lebanese
seems to be up
a queen for a rook and that is pretty
good
queens are better than rux in my humble
opinion
i do believe black has the edge
and also the edge on the clock that's
right
this is in fact a three plus zero event
so if you aren't moving quickly you can
very much
fall fall out on time
meaning lose on time don't know why i
said it like that but it's very very
easy to lose on time
in a three plus zero chess game it's
sort of a weird in between
between normal uh slow uh blitz like
five plus zero where you have a little
bit of time to think about your moves
but it's not quite bullet either if
you're just banging out chess moves and
you're making mistakes
you will lose on the board i really
enjoy it we'll see how it goes
with players here and it looks like we
have just one more game in progress
white makes a queen but it is swiftly
captured by black
and now we do have another flag with
black uh winning this one wait a second
now black losing this one
on time no black winning this one sorry
it's it's always
weird when uh one side is like promoting
so okay what do we have after round one
then let's check out our scoreboard
really quick which you can see here
looks like all the people that were
supposed to win did win did we have
any upsets in round one honestly i'm not
sure we did
i am not sure that we did
looks like toasted ravioli may have uh
just gotten a buy
in fact due to that having an odd number
of players
and yeah i i don't think we had any
upsets in round one that's
kind of crazy anyways round one is over
round two
is getting underway here so let's jump
back to it
jump back to it why don't we stick with
mystery
cpy uh
this is a name i have not recognized
before
and we have a king's indian defense
developing on the board
interesting that white decided to
include this move bishop
f4 this is yeah not really where the
bishop belongs in this opening and we
actually see white
swiftly rerouting it to uh to d4 which
does make a bit more sense
in general though i think white should
probably be capturing on d4
with the knight because as you see after
bishop takes d4 this bishop is very very
quickly just pushed away
and any ambitions that had of trading
itself off for
blacks being catered bishop are are
pretty much gone here
so we do see white wasting a little bit
of time in the opening
making one two three four five moves
with the bishop
but we'll see if black is able to
actually make use of it here
so far i think so good for black you see
knight g4 and this is likely with the
intent of dropping this knight back into
the e5 square
where it's just going to be a very very
strong centralized piece
yeah h3 uh is nice to kick the knight
away and yeah strangely we actually see
black putting this knight back on f6
i would have imagined knight e5 is just
a better square for this piece
uh black shouldn't really be shining
away from any trades and yeah now we see
the other knight come to e5 but
i don't know why this change in
structure is something that black really
uh
really was looking for here now
especially this bishop on g7 which was
once a very very strong
piece is now sort of blocked out of the
game with white's bishop actually
appearing to be the better piece
so 95 and dtx5 definitely not my
favorite continuation from black here
i would have rather seen this other
knight come to e5
keeping the black pieces a little bit
more fluid
yeah now i see no reason why white
shouldn't be better here charcoal just
seems to have a superior position
the one issue is this light squared
bishop but i don't think this is a
permanent issue
i think that's uh if white can
manufacture some sort of queen side pawn
storm
then white would have pretty decent
winning chances
okay bishop g5 is interesting looking
for this
pin on the dark squares to actually mean
something
i'm not sure that it's going to be the
most relevant and yeah we actually see
white shuffling
so it seems to be a position where white
is unsure what to do
uh that's why you see these sort of
strange shuffling moves with the bishop
but i think in the long run the plan for
white should be
to get these pawns rolling on the queen
side it's good to push where you have a
majority
uh if you can create a past pawn and
that's what white should be aiming to do
that's probably why we see bishop f8 uh
with the intent
of keeping track of some of these
squares in front of the pawns making
sure it's not so easy
to get them going knight b5 is a bit of
a fork we see
rook takes d2 as an inner meso
uh black now will have to deal with the
queen though and
yeah i'm not sure why white didn't
capture this free pawn you know
sometimes free pawns are free
gotta take those
elvis asks am i doing another stream at
8pm uh i'm doing
a stream every hour uh until 9 pm
central time so
uh after this tournament is over we will
have a little bit more normal end game
class which will be
your more historic uh lecture type class
rather than this
special tournament uh and then after
that i will be going live on twitch with
analyze your games where i
will analyze your games okay
uh we do see some developments now and
this uh
is now starting to turn in black's favor
as you would expect as black is the much
higher rate of player
uh that being said it's far from over
here what has changed is that now
uh black has managed to make this pawn
on e4 a very relevant weakness
whereas white's queen side pawns are no
longer very mobile
just tough to get them going
white miss knight takes a seven yeah i
was uh uh
yeah it just looked like a free pawn
that was my commentary
hey manny another tournament you missed
i think you
should still be able to join actually i
think you should be able to join
let me copy the link uh you will be
a couple rounds late but i do think late
joins are allowed this time around
in the meantime white's position has
just completely fallen apart here
and black is actually just delivering
delivering checkmate uh knight takes g3
was good instead
queen f1 seems to hang a queen which is
probably not what the doctor ordered
maybe charcoal's still in it after all
and we actually see
that the three plus 0 time control is
a little bit uh a little bit
you know difficult even for these high
rated players that being said i
wouldn't count mystery cpy out of it yet
white has a long way to go with these
pawns
while black's pawns seem to be rolling
king f1
but is it enough is it enough it's not
enough black is going to be queening
black is queening here
okay if b6 yeah that's a queen for black
the clocks are low though and wow what a
what a game
what a game i thought it was all over
queen f1 hanging a queen
going into an end game down a piece but
white unable to convert as black
uses the pawns rolls them up the board
this is definitely
definitely quite the game there ending
in a draw by stalemate of course
that's why you don't make three queens
only make two
only make as many as you need uh that is
probably the game of the tournament not
letting you play
yeah that is that is tough that it might
be too late it might be too late
uh so elvis uh i actually only
only look at the games that are posted
in the twitch chat for analyzer games i
can't keep track of them beforehand
that would be too much so what happened
here what should white have done to win
this game
i think the round is actually over so we
will look at it in a bit
and basically the point here is that in
these pawn races
you cannot waste any time so white
should have just been pushing this pawn
directly
and then in the meantime black is
pushing on this side
but perhaps it's not going to be as
relevant you might see something like
this happen
and now all white has to do is check the
king off of this square
and make a queen so that was white's
mistake
wasting a bit of time on this side of
the board making moves when you just
have to push over here as quickly as
possible
that's going to be interesting for the
standings now as the number two seed in
the event
has already given up a half point
perhaps national master limelight will
be able to
take that uh lead and run away with it
let's keep looking at some games though
we have excellent king
up against uh feta
feta caratus we have an e4 e5 uh italian
game
okay and looking around looks reasonable
so far
uh all right minus 84 for a stalemate
that that is difficult
that is difficult you don't have a
twitch accounts
well make one elvis make one join us
it's a lot of fun over on our twitch
channel
it's a lot of fun uh okay so what's
going on
in this game there's this weird sort of
uh tension between the knight and the
bishop uh
black was refusing to capture the dark
square bishop and white
uh up to that point was not doing
anything about it and that looked pretty
interesting to me i wonder why
uh i wonder why black didn't want to
capture here perhaps
black was concerned about building
white's center and giving up control of
d4
that makes a lot of sense to me at least
then we see bishop back to d2
probably because this threat of f4 was
coming and now we see
c4 that's an interesting break by white
okay an a3 and we do see a trade of a
knight for a bishop
so i am by no means an expert in the
italian
uh in these e4 e5 positions but to my
eyes
this looks very very good for black i
don't think you have to be an expert
to see that black has these rolling
pawns in the center
the bishop pair and already material
starts to fall
as it sort of had to do when white gets
completely pushed out of the center like
that
that's something you just have to avoid
this excellent king guy is underrated so
says you fisher said but looks like
excellent king is in quite a bit of
trouble here
getting outplayed in the opening by the
german
by the german
okay we see g3 and queen h3 so
the issue here is whenever you're facing
down this threat
normally what happens is you have to
make a weakness in your camp so here we
see excellent king chooses to play g3
which of course weakens these light
scores a little bit
perhaps h3 was another way to go but
that
also goes a long way towards weakening
squares around the king for example
f4 f3 against h3 would also cause some
issues
so black here is yes playing queen h4
in order to try and uh you know
checkmate
uh their opponent but it's not just
about a one move threat it's about
provoking this weakness
and now we'll see how black aims to
actually take advantage of it we have b3
bishop e5
knight g2 and yeah now knight e5 and
already
you see black looking to invade on these
newly weakened light squares in order to
win the game
we have a check king h8 now knight d4
uh is guarding this square temporarily
but this does give up the rook and now
after rook 88
queen takes f4 and yeah we see
we see that's uh white is under a lot of
pressure here probably going to go down
saying this because you beat a 2100 in
round two
ah that is quite the upset then
uh how come this isn't hosted on lee
chess says great wolf
that's a question for mike cummer uh
this
is one of many many many online
tournaments that the the chess club has
been hosting lately
uh all have some pretty fun and unique
prizes so i would recommend
checking out our website for more
details on that but mike has just chosen
to go with uh
with chess.com for our events
in the meantime uh white has resigned
uh because again these weaknesses around
the king were just too much and this was
actually a pretty cool game so let's
let's take it from the top here what
went wrong for white in this game
i i really wonder so far so good uh but
then yeah
white wastes a little bit of time early
on in the opening
and as a result of that black is sort of
able to break in the center with d5 now
e takes d5 i think is fine
i think all of these moves were pretty
reasonable uh bishop d2
even is not so crazy i think maybe c4
this was the big mistake at uh at the
moment
white has enough control in the center
to sort of sort of stay in the game
i think black may already be a little
bit better but white can at least
you know pressure e5 a little bit play
for a d4 break one day
after c4 those dreams are kind of gone
and it's just
a story of of black having total control
over the center of the board
and that will lose you the game
alright let's check out the game still
in progress we have one
between alessio and creative who both
still have a perfect score
and yeah this one looks interesting
looks like white is up
a pawn here looking to convert but as
always in three plus 0
it's just gonna be a flag fest right now
uh so we'll see who
has the faster mouse
black so far doing a good job as far as
chess is concerned making sure these
pawns don't go too far
then with the active king black has
actually leveled the material
although this pawn is gonna roll
although both pawns are going to roll
uh beautiful sacrifice there uh this
check
was perhaps missed yeah and i don't know
about letting white queen but
it's it's just a matter of moving
quickly and white
is the player who moved more quickly
that will be the match palestio
maintaining the perfect score
against a well-played game by creative
we're seeing the lower rate of players
really putting up a fight in these games
here i think that does it for round
three
uh let's take a quick look at our
standings before we move on
we have limelight still in first place
the number one seed going in remains
undefeated
we were keeping an eye on fett here who
also remains undefeated
and alessio with that flag late on late
in the round
does uh improve to three out of three
in the meantime charcoal who we were
keeping an eye on uh who had the
surprise
half a point against uh the number two
rated player
in the event also moves up to two and a
half so these four players the ones to
keep an eye on right now
definitely the ones to keep an eye on
all right moving over let's check out uh
board one matchup
alessio versus limelight can you not
join this tournament i think it is a
little bit too late we are in round
four now and there are only seven rounds
total uh
so you might have missed the bus on that
one
but uh we'll do more of these and there
are
more uh tournaments scheduled on the
saint louis chessclub.org website
if you want to check that out join some
future events you're more than welcome
to
for now though we're looking at board
one limelight versus alessio
we end up in another sicilian this time
an accelerated dragon
and white goes for the classic moratzi
bind
we saw black actually making a very
interesting trade of bishop for
knight on c3 which i'm gonna be honest
with you
i think that was a very very bad
decision uh this is a position
where white has taken dominance over the
light squares
using these pawns and generally black
fights back against this with a powerful
dark squared bishop whenever white puts
pawns on light squares
then the dark squares become weaker
black can take advantage
using this bishop instead though we see
black willingly give up this bishop
to quote-unquote fracture white's pawn
structure
and what has happened as a result of
that is black doesn't really have any
squares for his pieces this knight for
example
is lacking squares like f4 i suppose you
could jump to c5
but that is the problem that black is
facing in return
this weakness in the structure is what
black has been targeting
and now is looking to win a pawn on c4
in the meantime though you know
neglecting uh castling the king
this knight is getting a little bit
dominated by a white's powerful dark
squared bishop
and it's going to be interesting to see
if black is really
doing all right in this position without
the bishop which title is harder to
achieve
national master or feed a master so feed
a master is definitely
the harder title uh
although the the process for for getting
the titles is a little bit different
national master is a nationally acquired
title used through
national chess federations the the us
chess federation is how i got mine
there's also a canadian national master
title there's also
i believe uh maybe not an english one
but
a few other countries have the national
master title uh whereas the feed a
master title is through
fide which is the international chess
federation so different stuff
different titles different you know
organizations even but
uh definitely b-day master is the harder
one
okay so what happened here white lost
all the pawns and
that is the end of the story i suppose
so yeah queen d5
probably not my favorite move i think
white had to go a little bit crazy here
and try to get some some immediate
counter play maybe something like rook
a4
was actually perfectly fine just
guarding this pawn preparing to double
and i think white might be better but
instead we see all the pieces being
liquidated
and rather than even taking this pawn we
see now
black is a pawn to the good in a four
versus five rook end game
uh now a four versus three rook end game
and i do wanna say that four versus five
is actually uh i think a little bit
harder to draw than four versus three
i think the body of theory in these end
games usually says
that uh the the fewer number of pawns
that the easier it is
to draw up into up to you know one pawn
versus two
obviously zero pawn versus one is a
different uh shebang but one pawn versus
two tends to be pretty easy to draw
two pawns versus three also pretty easy
to draw three versus four there's a
little bit of room for play
and four versus five there's even more
so uh that
being said it looks like we are now down
to a one versus two scenario but
important to note that this pawn is on
e5 and not g5 this pawn already being
passed means that black actually has
very good winning chances
and yeah now rook d2 white's king is
getting dominated and actually the g
pawn has fallen and limelight will be
the victor
both on the board and on the clock so
limelight
maintains the perfect score here let's
see how
board two did and yeah f-e-t uh
feta karates also maintains a perfect
score against charcoal who has been
battling it out with some very high
rated players
so we'll see that match up in the next
round what other games do we have going
on here
we have excellent king we have mike
again take another look at mike
uh let's check out toasted ravioli the
underdog of the event at the 300 rating
is actually doing quite well in this
game very interesting toasted
ravioli could be looking to score a
point here against allison hart
toasted ravioli the underdog and the
reason why i say
they're probably looking to score a
point here they are you know up 20
seconds right the the position on the
board is still very complex
i honestly i would assume that white is
better here just by virtue of having an
extra pawn
but especially on the clock this is
where this game is going to be decided
so incredible stuff from toasted ravioli
800 points underdog this may be the
upset of
the of the tournament here 800 is a lot
of rating points
uh and with that allison goes down minus
24
plus 73 for the ravioli not a bad day
not a bad day on the job for toasted
ravioli
uh last up mike is still duking it out
and
mike now just needs to deliver a
checkmate with four seconds left
and does it so much better than you aka
mike comer
wins his game all right that leaves us
with two
undefeated players keeping an eye on
this scoreboard here
both limelight and uh fedocuratus
on four out of four that's good
stuff good stuff
yup as far as why are people playing
we're over
2000 that's a question for them but as i
said
sort of at the top of the hour um
the road to 2000 is for all players you
can be
aiming to achieve the 2000 rating from
any direction i don't judge
maybe they are simply looking to
decrease their rating by a couple
hundred points you know
nothing wrong with that some people
they're just too good at chess they just
want it they want to be a little bit
worse
so they watch this class uh okay
what's going on in this game we see
white going for an early knight e5
supporting it with d4 and f4 in the
meantime black
plays an early c5 looking to break down
these dark squares
how did we get here we see the exchange
qgd with bishop g5 and early knight f3
and yeah just as i said knight f5 and f
or 95 and f4 okay some big decisions
being made on the board here and
actually
big tactics being hung it looks like so
i was going to say i'm not in love with
how black actually handled this by
taking on e5
i think probably it was a bit better to
go for a massive amount of space on the
queen's side
start rolling these pawns down the board
uh and in the meantime keeping an eye on
the king's side threats uh just sort of
as you go
after this though yeah now this was an
unfortunate tactic to hang
this bishop is actually overworked
defending both knight and pawn
so knight takes d5 comes on the board
white upon to the good
in the meantime the queen g5 is perhaps
actually a really annoying
threat uh made by black here i suppose
rook to f4 could be tried but maybe
knight
takes e3 there anyways really crazy
stuff going on
crazy stuff
yes in fact they should cedar they are
not
using the class properly if they don't
so yeah i think
rook f4 would have been an interesting
idea here with the point being if bishop
takes d5
be met by queen takes on g4 or takes on
g4
but after rook f4 i think the awkward
move for white was knight takes e3
when now it is white's knight who is
overworked so queen b3 instead
and we actually now see a queen takes e3
yeah i don't know if i'm in love with
the bishop takes d5 trade seems a little
bit unnecessary
um i think just simply knight takes e3
was
was just winning the game right i think
knight takes e3 is winning the game here
you threaten checkmate
you threaten this knights and knight
takes e3 isn't playable due to the queen
hanging
so knight takes e3 big miss by black
there but
instead okay instead queen takes e3
actually picks up this bishop so
black still winning in this line as well
and
yeah i was going to say that maybe e7
was a tactic here but i i suppose it
doesn't work so we see e takes f7 and
queen e2
and yeah definitely not the simplest
position uh in the world
yet for black definitely some work still
to be done
but i suspect that that work shouldn't
be too difficult
to to get done here uh we see black
going after this pawn
on d4 i would say be a little bit
cautious if black does take here
you might see some ricky a tactics and
if we're back to d8 then take
take and queen uh also some tactics for
white to fall for as well with
rook d1 stuff being uh not advisable due
to knight f2
and rook takes f7 this is the game of
overworked pieces this is really the
game
of overworked pieces uh every other move
it feels like there's an overworked
pieces tactic
uh all right queen to c4 and we just see
a doubling of the rooks
i probably would have just captured on
f1 and taken on d5 while i could
uh now black does take control over this
f file but
at the same time the the d pawn gets to
live to see another day
something i would not want to have
happen
if i had the black pieces the name of
the game is simplification
uh when you're up a piece and this is
the opposite
of simplification we now see black
sacrificing
the extra night uh for this rook f2 idea
and like i said simplification is what
black should be going for
here this is not simple in fact i don't
even know if black is winning anymore
maybe there's a rook takes f1 with queen
e3 idea
but i honestly don't see how it's
working
okay now we see queen b6 and this move
is clever to put the queen opposite the
king and maybe this is
this is in fact a winning idea here but
a lot more complex than it needed to be
for fedocuratus i don't know
about uh these decisions with knight f2
knight takes h3 and leaving the d-pawn
on the board
crazy stuff but he did get get a
resignation out of limelight so
fedocaratus with the upset
catapults himself into first place ahead
of the national master
all right that being said there are
other games still underway so let's
check them out
uh why don't we check back in on toasted
ravioli i just like the username so much
we ought to see what's going on
and looks like a tough day for toasted
ravioli here or does it
looks like a complicated day for toasted
ravioli looks complicated i
have tried a couple times now to count
the pieces but it doesn't matter this is
made in one
that's made in one toasted ravioli on a
tear
gaining 150 rating points so far 150
rating points
that's wild that's wild
toasted ravioli cannot be stopped cannot
be stopped
truly the dark horse of the event a
couple more games underway we do see
excellent king here up against alessio
and this looks like a losing king in
pawn end game
but the question is will whites
lose on the board or will white be
flagged
looks like white is playing to win on
time
as alessio is showing that
speed is not their strong suit oh no
they're gonna get flagged they have to
make three more moves
oh wow that's a heartbreaker i wonder if
some time
if some connection was going on there uh
with some bad italy internet
i don't know that was that that was bad
that was real bad
goodness gracious all right uh that
actually does conclude the fifth round
let's take a quick look at the
scoreboard
we have fedocaratus on the perfect score
and actually three players chasing him
uh excellent king limelight and chess
lebanese salah
all on four out of five looking to knock
fedocuratus
off of that top pedestal there we'll see
if chess lebanese
is the one to do it looks like we have
an early scotch game
and after c3 it is a scotch gambit
all right fun stuff we see takes on c3
takes on c3
daniel is going to rename ah manny's
gonna rename
uh himself uh roasted ravioli daniel
going for boasted ravioli
if i were a better commentator i would
also come up with a funny ravioli name
but i will leave that to the chat room
coasted ravioli coasted that's that's a
word
that's fair coasted
what's going on in this chess game i
don't know i don't know i haven't been
watching
have you guys been watching we get the
scotch game bishop c4 take take take
bishop a3 the classic
scotch move bishop a3 uh okay
d6 castles 97 it looks like this is
going well for black to be honest with
you although f4 might be
changing some minds f4 might be changing
some minds i don't think it's changing
mine though in fact bishop g4 is a
playable move but
i would have even looked at knight g4
with dual threats of knight f2 and
knight e3 that looked
kind of difficult to stop instead we get
bishop g4 and actually now knight d3
with tempo
but black's pieces yeah are
unfortunately sort of hanging together
by a thread
this should be two seems like the only
way to keep everything together now
with both pieces hanging but maybe this
is actually
this is good maybe this is just good
unless white is able to make some like
really concrete threat right away
looks like knight f2 is going to be
difficult to stop maybe the simple move
knight
d2 just sacrificing the exchange here
and that is actually what we do see
played
impeach ravioli no comment
no comment on impeached ravioli um
okay knight d2 sacrificing the exchange
black doesn't want it plays queen e8
trying to keep everything together
uh how do you join the tourney so yeah
unfortunately the this is the second to
last round so you will have to catch us
next time
uh but let me pull up a link for you
guys let me pull up a link for you guys
because these are excellent questions on
how to join the tournaments
so on the saint louis chessclub.org
website we actually do have a clubs
tournament club tournaments page and a
lot of these tournaments are in person
uh at the st louis chess club but a lot
of them are also online
uh so you are all welcome to join those
all right what do we have here we see a
couple more moves being played bishop c2
trying to get rid of this
knight and succeeding but not before
black collects this extra exchange on
f1 in the meantime though who cares
about the extra exchange uh
white is is playing for checkmate here
f6 coming on the board
and now knight g6 but this feels very
loose
feels very very loose we can rip open
the dark squares now
with pawn takes on g7 and you might even
see a rerouting of this bishop to
further stamp this uh this
this attack e5 another great uh
clearing move allowing this bishop
access into the game
i don't know if it's actually my
favorite though because what is this
bishop even doing
and in fact i would have maybe preferred
to see the move queen takes e5 offering
a trade of queens right away
uh instead though we see takes on g6 and
yeah this attack is starting to uh
to go a little bit sour i think for for
white i'm not seeing
the the forcing continuations anymore
that give
white counter play rook f5 defends the
the e5 pawn adequately it's not
comfortably
but it is adequately or queen c6
giving up the e5 pawn still not my
favorite thing here chess lebanese takes
with
check now and after yeah king h7 this
this was a real losing
losing move i think queen c6 just no
need
to uh to allow white to get in like this
but now bishop takes c5 i think this is
a game of blunders here this seems like
a game of blunders and that's just bound
to happen in three plus so
but why not give check why not bring the
queen in with check
and you know continue the game knight c4
to follow going 95
but instead we just see more traits and
that's definitely not what white needs
right now
white needs a forcing attack to uh to
complicate things
queen f5 and yeah black's play is easy
you just simply uh
offer a lot of trades and you know get
closer to that end game where you're
just up material
i think fedocaratus is gonna stay on a
perfect score
i think that's what's happening here
with a huge 50 second time edge
all that karats has to do is not hang
checkmate at queen b1 now forced we see
this rook coming off the board
don't play queen f1 knights move
backwards knights move backwards queen
takes a2 does seem fine though
does seem fine king h7 also why not
just a good solid move 92 i'm playing
queen f1 now
get these queens off the board that's
the only way i lose the game
even bishop takes g1 now is perfectly
fine and i think fedocratis is going to
secure himself a place
uh as at least at a very minimum
tying for first you know a tie for first
place i think is the best anybody else
could do
with veda karates still on a perfect
score after six rounds
uh assuming this game does go his way
we've seen chess lebanese play quickly
before and we're seeing it here again
but 30 seconds to three is going to be
tough to make up
no matter who you are you could be
andrew tang you'd be eric hansen it
doesn't matter
30 seconds is too much and we do
actually see
feta winning by checkmate fatih
maybe i don't know how to say names
anyways that is
one of the last games of the round and
we see flipping over to
the standings again and actually we were
on the stand we were on the full screen
view the whole time so here's my face if
you missed it now back to the full
window capture here
uh we have photocratis on six out of six
and limelight does move up to five out
of six perhaps the only person who could
fetch fedocaratus
in this final round but uh nobody can
surpass
surpass fedocaratus on a perfect
score really crazy stuff uh and so in
order for that to happen we actually
have to keep an eye on two games
better corradus is up against mystery
cpy and is not making a move
you have to move betty karates you have
to make a move in the meantime
limelight also has to take out chess
lebanese who just fell
against fetty karates
what is the prize first place prize is
um a lesson with me and here's my face
again sorry i forgot to show it
during the entirety of that last game
but i'm back i'm back now
a lot of keep track of here for me a lot
to keep track of all right we get c3
and the knight is under threat is there
a prize
yes so the top three places actually get
a prize
uh all top three places get a free entry
into a tournament in february which is
on that link i posted
a little bit earlier it is the february
17th event play
like a champion today and the prize
uh the prizes in that tournament are
free lessons with the resident
grand master which is good stuff you
don't want to uh to pass those up
first place price actually also gets a
free lesson with me so
if you uh want something like that
you should play in these tournaments is
there any consolation praise for last
no but we will be giving toasted ravioli
uh
uh something not not something but like
you know some sort of fake award
because it's been a lot of fun following
his
uh or their success and demises
throughout this event
okay what's going on in this game this
is really important for our standings we
have
uh early trades we have early trades
okay so white
does this sort of double fiance setup
and then eventually breaks with the move
e4 so not too crazy
so far the queens come off the board as
a result
then knight h4 is an interesting
decision allowing bishop takes in this
doubling of pawns
we then see this knight getting into
some trouble here getting a little bit
stuck on the c2 square rook d2 and
everything's still keeping together and
yeah to my eyes it looks like black is
is simply crushing it in this game
bishop takes h4 i think should not have
been allowed this
pawn structure is is pretty terrible and
now white's pieces
are are playing ketchup this bishop is
actually going to die if it steps to a3
rook a2 is hitting it still after bishop
a1
now this bishop is effectively dead
because there's just no place
where uh where this bishop can go why i
think he served good for the purpose of
underdog in entertainment
uh there's only so many prizes we can
give away i can't just make the rules up
on the spot
i'm not the organizer of the tournament
if you want new prizes made up for on
the spot
you gotta talk to mike cummer he's in
charge of these things
all right we see white uh trying to
activate the king because it's
impossible to activate the rest of their
pieces
uh so not a bad idea and in the meantime
maybe uh black is is looking for some
checkmates although it's tough to
get rid of all of the dark squares
yeah and now actually though black is
seemingly achieving this checkmate uh
king h6
was in the air completely trapping this
king on
f4 now perhaps the simple move rook f3
is unstoppable mate with
f6 on the next turn um instead we see
bishop f3 which is not unstoppable mate
but honestly it doesn't matter a great
deal at this point white is
pretty busted here pretty busted rook f3
would have been a nice way to finish it
off though
in the meantime fedocaratus has actually
already won
against mystery cpy how has this
happened
how has this happened how have this
happened we have
some sort of sicilian here what kind of
sicilian let's take a look
we have a sicilian naidorf okay all
right with an early bishop d3
e5 92 makes sense so far bishop b7 and
castles and so far it looks like black
isn't really doing anything wrong
we see this move f4 and threats
on the e4 pawn takes takes
yeah so far so good it looks like the
opening actually didn't go too poorly
for uh for black here but we do have now
the strong knight on f5 to deal with
and it looks like this is what went
wrong for uh
what went wrong for the black pieces
here definitely you can't let this
knight on at five stand forever
probably in this position black should
very seriously be considering a move
such as g6 or a move you know even like
rook
not rook c7 but maybe even rook c6
guarding the sixth rank and allowing
this bishop to come back to help defend
some of these light squares that's where
it all goes wrong
it looks like fedocaratus is able to
just fork the king and the queen
and declare victory in the meantime
limelight does go down against chess
lebanese
uh by resignation looks like some kind
of checkmate was still coming in that
game
and that pretty much wraps up our our
tournament here we have
uh two more games still in progress mike
is still playing against
b file going for a five out of seven
score which is perfect
uh b file also playing for a five out of
seven score
and yeah let's see here looks like mike
is playing for the dirty flag here
seems like mike's playing for the flag
although mike does pick up the
the b6 pawn now 92 not really a move in
the english at least
you thought the english night or that
was not the english attack
um that was bishop d3 rather than bishop
e3
which uh the bishop d3 lines are sort of
just
less popular ways to play the bishop e2
lines
uh which is why you saw a lot of similar
ideas to uh to that
and yeah mike now ahead 10 seconds looks
like they are
are going to uh mike's going to be able
to to pull this one out
here we get g5 rick f1 and
kings in a box white has more rooks
white has more time
that'll be the match i think that
concludes the tournament i think the
tournament is over
let's flip back over to the full
standings here
and we can see that fetty karates is
your tournament champion
chess lebanese salah taking second place
by defeating limelight in the final
round
and excellent king who we i believe only
saw i think we saw the two games where
they they didn't do so well
but they won the the five other games
that they played
uh and take home the the bronze trophy
on tie breaks
mike also up there in contention with
five out of seven but could not
break the leaderboard due to the poor
tie breaks i think
the longer you hold the perfect score
and the better tie breaks you tend to
have
and so we see fetty karates with the
victory
and it appears to be akus kara
in the chat room when do you get the
lesson uh
well that is a great question a great
question for
mike cummer go ahead and send us a
dm either on leachates or chess.com
or uh i don't know how mike has has the
prices set up probably you're supposed
to email mike
probably you're supposed to email mike
yeah i don't really want to
just announce my email right here on the
stream but
i will get it to you okay so i will get
my email and we will schedule something
okay chess king got third
congratulations
chess king aka excellent king on getting
third place
and thank you guys all for uh for
playing here today
uh i think that is going to be the
conclusion
of our show here today thank you all
again so much for watching if you want
to stick around
for the end game class that we'll be
starting momentarily we are a little bit
over time already
so let's uh get to it soon what happened
to toasted ravioli this is an important
question that needs to be answered
they finished with three points out of
seven a very respectable score
uh tying i believe for 15th place which
is almost top half
uh any consolation prize for seventh not
quite not quite
mystery man your second you get
something
so yes the tournament details i will
link one more time
in the chat here um actually this is not
the right tournament
let me grab it and i will link it in the
chat and then we are going to call it a
day
as the
endgame class is getting started
momentarily
so go head over to the other
stream listed on our youtube channel
known as the endgame class
click on that that's where i will be
live in another moment
isn't analytic game analysis now no
that's after the endgame class 8 pm
central time
for game analysis 7 p.m central time for
the uh endgame class so thank you all so
much for watching thank you guys for
playing
congratulations to akis kara chess king
for getting third place and
fisher seb for getting second place uh i
had a lot of fun going over this
hopefully you enjoyed it
as well uh and with that ma as always my
name is caleb denby and i will see you
next time goodbye